hey guys how's it going so I always get
questions about how do you edit your
videos it's kind of a complex question
to answer so I thought I would give you
guys a quick little time lapse at the
end of this vlog of what I did to edit
the video so here's the vlog and stay
tuned until the end to watch me edit it
really really fast hey guys how's it
going
so I come downstairs and desgas hey
watch this woo oh my god I'm Becca
okay it's weird it makes me feel really
uncomfortable it is a lemon yeah this is
me so smooth though oh my gosh this is
I'm so amused look like a full-service
circus over here we're off on a mini
adventure to Malibu
since jazz and then their flight got
canceled the connecting flights to
Chicago stop and get some coffee first
and then we're gonna drive Maddy from
the backseat and he's
you love it
Samantha Malu cafe and the problem is
they don't start serving dinner till
five but it took us alone to get here
fluted mine right now
Ben's got puff duty now this lace is oh
so cute I love it we came here if you
guys remember the vlog way well I
thought somebody shot me
we came here with my parents and it's a
super cute little cafe they've got hash
tags everywhere
it's the hash tag Melanie pepper
not would you get a whole animal I love
pretzels good my Maddy look go bud that
pretty little girl Matt is the dog
Matt let me go girl you are he likes big
do it they're gonna be on their bed nice
little dinner supposed to be a brunch we
were trying to leave I was like oh guys
it'll be nice to do a post birthday
party brunch yeah well we didn't get
seated until 5:00 because they started
serving dinner then and they closed for
after lunch so we're here and it's
called oh boy he's got the life back
here time in buckle lumen what do you
were Cameron right here I'll shoot Hey
look no cute okay ready here's the slam
now you want to try on an outfit for our
friend what do we have for you well two
favorite outfit Oh
oh he hates it
and now time to watch the editing of the
fly
kiss tight of my heart fly and it is
getting dangerous I don't wanna feel it
inside
your words are so contagious
Oh mine you don't wanna be described no
having a reaction
oh I can feel
we let go
things I've never done before plays
again
my skin
let's keep dancing bye
painting the sky and ant or chemistry
heart beats riding time mmm you Pakula
Grampa day I don't wanna be distracted
I'm gonna no reaction oh I gave it to
you getting through your stay
Oh fine you don't wanna be distraction
oh I can burn it up can I lose
we let go
do things I've never done get to know
I'm broken and even in the sky could
fall things again blows nice kiss
I'm fine
my skills
thank guys for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed this I've had a lot of fun doing
sort of the fun little screen capture
videos I've also been doing a couple
things where I'm reading your guys's
comments leave me some below I'm never
sure which video I'm gonna do reading
comments but it's usually what I have a
vlog that's not that long
hey hey I'm gonna make it a little bit
longer about reading some of your
comments from the previous video I'll
see you guys the next vid I love you are
you ready the couch that was here is now
downstairs where'd he go what do you do
when you're looking for undies he's an
undefeated loves just you the bad news
that's what on these are you put your
feet in move as you guys later hope you
guys have a great week peace